so we have a form of tax National
Insurance specifically targeted working
people then you have vat which is on
consumption now very rich people consume
very very small percentage of their
income so they pay very little v80 so a
vat Target that Ordinary People National
Insurance Target that working people
income tax avoidable for the rich
inherent stocks avoidable for the rich
the end result is you have a tax system
which looks Progressive for ordinary
people because you're only comparing
yourself to people around you who are
ordinary people at the same time you
have this small group of people who are
phenomenally Rich who are increasingly
buying everything
you don't often get to see in day-to-day
life that are paying nothing generating
huge amounts of income and using that
income to buy the rest of the assets so
um who pays tax uh if you're a working
person in an ordinary financial
situation uh you who doesn't pay tax
very wealthy families uh the people who
receive your mortgage payments your rent
payments
um the money you spend on food and bills
they don't pay any tax on that
and they I've been using that money to
buy the rest of the wealth